[Musik]
die geschichte deutschland tausende
jahre erfolg mit doktor iv hausen
herzlich willkommen zum telekolleg afd
geschichte was die mainstream historiker
gern verschweigen deutschland ist eines
der ganz wenigen länder das 1000 jahre
am stück wirklich nur erfolg hatte wir
haben so einen lauf
je nachdem wie man rechne ich meine
deutschland in dem sinne gibt es doch
eigentlich erst seit 1871 wie kommen sie
auf 1000 jahre hat das sagt man halt so
das tausendjährige reich
das ist eine redewendung was ich doch
nicht wo sie herkommt im kinder
schokolade sind ja auch wieder kinder
noch schokolade
sie können sogar noch viel weiter zurück
gehen 9 nach christus hermann der
cherusker schmeißt die römer raus der
war quasi der erfinder der abschiebung
diese blöden römer mit ihren
wasserleitungen dank hermann haben die
deutschen noch jahrhunderte weiter vom
baum geschossen
ja kaum sind jahre erfolg da können sie
irgendein datum neben oliver was weiß
ich die krönung karls des großen in
aachen im jahr 800 oder kurz danach im
jahr 812 die geburt alexander gauland es
gibt so viel auf das wir stolz sein
können
in sexten in zieht um nur mal die ganzen
karls zu nennen die deutsche geschichte
wimmelt von großartigen karls karl der
käfer auch auch karl der große zum
beispiel hat die sachsen umgebracht ja
weil die nicht zum christentum
übertreten wollten weder können wir
heute noch so viel daraus lernen
warum haben wir dann 89 die sachsen
wieder reingelassen das war es keiner
das ist doch nicht der punkt ja nur
deutsche erfolge bitte heiliges
römisches reich deutscher nation bis
1806 später rein bund deutscher bund
norddeutscher bund 18 71 reichsgründung
damals war der kilimandscharo der
höchste deutsche berg
19 14 bis 18 die franzosen zwingen uns
den ersten weltkrieg auf kommt zweimal
republik gegen bis 33 dann vogelschutz
und dann bundesrepublik noch fragen
aber das war noch nicht alles erfolge
natürlich da haben sie völlig recht
es gab leider auch die dunklen jahre
september 2015
die irre arzt persönlich alle
schlagbäume hoch armes deutschland
wir wollen es so an unsere enkel
übergeben wie unsere großväter und väter
das für uns getan haben
wir wollen das land wieder so wie wir es
von unseren großvätern übernommen haben
heißt das wir müssen wieder alles kaputt
machen
nein nicht wir was machen die alliierten
nach dem nächsten vogel schiff jetzt
habe ich etwa aus meine damen und herren
vielen dank